c'est un peu comme dans l'atelier du
père noël sauf qu'au lieu des lutins ce
sont les petites mains de la famille de
véronique qui s'activent sous sa
houlette pour recréer un univers
familier à tous ceux qui ont plus de 60
ans celui des jouets d'antan suis en
train de retaper des petits chevaux de
bois donc il faut qu'on sait il faut
peindre et puis après on va les mettre
dans un petit manège et megan son épouse
pour qu'elle soit
jour là je suis un de construire un
petit shoot ce n'est pas pour prouver
parce que c'est une fille mais en fait
monsieur de mou déjà puisque vous y
allez en train de bourrer l'autre petit
fils à jo je suis en train de
confectionner un petit camion les
camions qu'on faisait avant on jouait
avec des fondations qui ont travaillé
donc je sens même de terminer palau peut
aller plus vite qui pour être plus sûre
demi mesure j'ai comparé du gavage ce
petit cheval bois a déjà plus de 30 ans
et le remonte à la première fois où
véronique à recréer cet univers c'était
pour un festival de la ville de
fort-de-france fin des années 80 il va
subir un ravalement complet
une somme de famille nombreuse et
mon papa il faisait toujours d'aider des
meubles parce que ça revenait du moins
cher et j'ai aimé le voir je jouais
toujours à ses pieds jeu mais comme
j'étais tout petit et je devais avoir 8
10 ans et je jouais avec les copeaux de
bois parce que quand on passait le rabot
ça sans rouler et puis je crois que
c'est de là que j'ai j'ai aimé ça j'ai
toujours des colliers
oui alors va mettre encore un peu plus
tu sais pourquoi parce que en fait quand
c'est pas bien dur bien bourré le cou à
la longue
l'enfant a beaucoup joué avec le choucas
aucun outil n'a de secret pour véronique
qui adore bricoler d'ailleurs son petit
camion de bois va vite prendre forme
ça m'est arrivé de faire un petit camion
à l'occasion après le festival
effectivement peut-être deux ou trois
années après sa manette arrivée dans
l'endroit confectionner mais n'ont pas
de commerces ou et moi ça va tous nous
rester dans notre espace puis de temps
en temps va jouer une quinzaine de
jouets vont être des mains de véronique
et ses soeurs avant noël ils ne seront
pas destinés à la vente
mais à la demande elle pourrait bien
accepter de faire le bonheur de quelques
petits enfants